none of us is strong enough or smart
enough to do this thing called life by
ourselves
none of us um and i think we forget that
and especially in this day and age
um where i think we've overemphasized
rugged individualism
as a society i think we've uh
overemphasized
um putting on a happy face every day you
know we have a uh
especially the younger generation but we
have a time where we're all incredibly
good at curating our lives
um and putting on social media just how
great everything is
or we've misunderstood that being
vulnerable
does not mean turning on a you know
uh turning on your phone and and making
a sort of
a confessional to no one to the room and
then posting it online
that's not vulnerability simply saying
you're sad and then posting it online
uh that's just broadcasting um
true vulnerability is is is is inter
interpersonal um uh it's much much
scarier to tell to actually tell someone
um
it goes to my favorite definition of
love my favorite definition of love
is giving someone the power to destroy
you and trusting they won't use it
um that's vulnerability